[Musik]
das ist ein film über die sherpas am
mount everest die mit 8850 metern
höchsten berg der welt
für einmal geht es nicht um die
westlichen bergsteiger die jedes jahr
schlange stehen um sich ihren traum vom
mount everest zu erfüllen im mittelpunkt
stehen die sherpas die ihren kunden
diesen traum ermöglichen die rasten
tragen und den weg zum gipfel
vorbereiten
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
es ist die geschichte über ihren
verdienten gipfelerfolg es ist aber auch
ein film der zeigt wie sich die sherpas
wird das leben ihre kunden einsetzen und
sich dadurch selber in todes gefahr
bringen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und das sahen sie in der letzten folge
noch schärfer der junge chef des sherpa
teams aus dem basislager mit dem
expeditionsleiter kari kobler um die
löhne für sein team für seine kunden
berät er über 40 kilo material durch den
berüchtigten qubo eiskalt ins lager 1
auf 5900 meter
[Musik]
risiko gibt es kein geld wenn du das
risiko nicht auf die nehmen willst du
verdienst doch kein gutes geld
das risiko gehört einfach dazu london
ist eine legende er stand über 13 mal
auf dem everest um geld zu verdienen für
seine familie
groß ist die angst dass er einmal nicht
mehr wiederkommt
wir sind gezwungen risiken einzugehen
viele sagen es hat schon ohne last
schwierig in der höhe zu laufen
aber wir tragen doppelte ja dreifache
lasten wir müssen auf 30 bis 40 kilo
schleppen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie und die anderen sherpas der
schweizer expedition von kari kobler
befinden sich zum ersten mal im aufstieg
zum lager 2 auf 6400 metern jeder mit
über 20 kilo gepäck auf dem rücken immer
wieder überqueren sie die
gletscherspalten auf den leitern welche
die sogenannten eisfall doktoren gelegt
haben
lasst ist heute etwas schwer
das ist mein erster abstecher ins lager
2 in dieser saison
es ist mühsam in dieser hitze zu laufen
vielleicht ist es so weil es das erste
mal ist
[Musik]
norbu der chef des sherpa teams genannt
siehe da ist bereits vorher eingetroffen
und beginnt das lager zwei aus zu
schaufeln
unter dem eis lauern tiefe
gletscherspalte wie games.com sie kommst
hier erstellen die sherpas in den
nächsten tagen ein weiteres zeltdorf mit
allem komfort
alle sind erschöpft vom langen aufstieg
ein ziemlich harter aufstellt es ist
nicht hart aber mein kopf tut mir weh
ich muss eine tablette nehmen stellt
drei zelte da drinnen vier bis fünf
teilnehmer werden heute hier oben
schlafen
kommt jungs was dann ist ein platz
vorbereitende müssen arbeiten keine zeit
zum ausruhen
es ist einfach ein basecap zu arbeiten
denn das liegt tiefer unten
dieses lager er befindet sich auf 6100
meter beim mit der schaufel 23 mal
zuschlägt kann man außer atem
es ist mühsam zu arbeiten schärfer denn
die bringt 20 liter kerosin das zum
kochen gebraucht wird hagen und die
anderen sherpas bauen ein komplettes
küchenzelt auf der koch fällt in den
nächsten wochen hier oben für alle die
mahlzeiten zubereiten und nicht mehr ins
basislager runtergehen für die
expedition mitglieder errichten die
sherpas schlafzelte sowie ein geräumiges
es zählt den schweizer bergsteigern die
40000 franken für die expedition bezahlt
haben soll es auch hier oben an nichts
mangeln
inzwischen trifft london sie mit
weiterem expedition material ein
es ist über 25 grad die sonne brennt und
dort sie leidet da noch nicht an die
automatisiert ist
ich habe wenn ich mich bücken habe ich
das gefühl zu fallen
die küchenmannschaft sucht inzwischen im
gletscher frisches eis um damit wasser
abzukochen
dabei stoßen sie auf einen grausigen
fund
direkt neben ihrem lager platz
der gletscher hat gleichen teil eines
bergsteigers der vor jahren in eine
gletscherspalte gefallen ist freigegeben
vielleicht verfolgte ich das noch im
traum dies ist nur eine von vielen
leichen die irgendwo ist verschollen
sind viele der verunfallten bergsteiger
werden nie mehr gefunden was noch
niemand weiß auch diese expedition wird
nicht zum unglück verschont bleiben
leben und tod am everest sind nahe
beieinander
für die sherpas geht die arbeit weiter
um bei kräften zu bleiben gehört eine
pause mit viel flüssigkeit dazu dann
bricht londoner auf erklärt ins über
1000 meter tiefer gelegene base camp
zurück um neue lasten zu holen
rund fünf tage lang werden die sherpas
nun für die teilnehmer immer wieder
material vom basislager ins lager zwei
hinauf transportieren müssen
norbu bleibt im lager 2 und organisiert
die transporte erstens ein solar
ladegerät zweitens zwei große matten
drittens ein medizinkoffer vierten skero
sehen
fünftens ein großer petroleum kocher
sowie butter und fleisch verstanden
im basislager genießen in der es die
beiden walliser expeditionsteilnehmer
patrick gruhn und meinrad mittel ihren
freien tag
sie sind beeindruckt was die sherpas
leisten mit 50 kilo sehen
diese prüft kampf 2 und wieder ist es
unglaublich wenn das kino vor 5 300
stunden woche
die sherpas leiden in der höhe genauso
wie jeder andere westliche bergsteiger
sie dürfen sich aber nichts anmerken
lassen und lächeln immer freundlich wie
london
[Applaus]
auch wenn es weh tut man muss immer
stehvermögen zeigen
dazu sind wir gezwungen es gibt ja passt
die lassen alle last zurück wenn sie
sich nicht wohl fühlen
einige kehren sogar um ohne etwas zu tun
aber die bekommen dann später probleme
wenn der us dollar schwäche hin und
sieht wehrte sich in kathmandu
beschweren und sagen wir würden unsere
arbeit nicht verrichten und simulieren
dann bekommen wir keine anstellung mehr
die übrigen expedition mitglieder sind
auf 6400 meter ins lager zwei hoch
gelaufen
sie werden freundlich mit heißem tee
willkommen geheißen
unterdessen haben die sherpas alles
hochgeschleppt nabu macht innen tat
stück für dich wie viele gaskartusche 6
und verzichtet mammut seile 11 mm wie
viele unter anderem stehen 50 flaschen
mit lebenswichtigen sauerstoff für den
transport in weitere hochlager bereit
ich muss die karabiner kontrolliere ich
dachte werden genug davon
ich habe fünf wie vor stehen auf der
liste
lasst uns die zelte aufräumen und das
gepäck der mitglieder in einem anderen
zelt abstellen dann ist unsere arbeit
für heute zählen jetzt wäre alles bereit
um die weiteren hochlager einzurichten
doch dann kommt alles anders
wir schreiben den 29 april 2008 im
basislager land militärhelikopter die
nepalesische regierung sperrt den berg
wichtig chinesen die olympische fackel
auf den gipfel des everest gebracht
haben
der aufstieg ist nur bis lager 2
gestartet
rund 500 bergsteiger sind im basislager
blockiert und müssen warten kürzlich zu
machen das ist wahr das ist worden auf
chinesen und taxis das sind sagte mit
viel wachs und liebte heavy trader hat
patrick nutzt die zeit und ist in die
geschichte des everest eingetaucht
es ist ein buch über die geschichte der
cerpos von judy und tashi tensing dem
enkel von djerba den sieg sie erzählen
wie das vor der sherpas in die berge kam
als träger und berg führen
am schluss gibt es eine liste mit allen
stars die auf dem everest waren da hab
ich dann an dich lambo oder london die
aus peru entdeckt
was heißt lambo groß lang wie soll ich
dich auch lamberti nennen
ja wusstest du dass es eine liste gibt
wo draufsteht ist
was ist heute der rekord es ist apa
sherpa 17 mal
der zweite ist teilnehmer und dann droht
sie ja er war 13 mal loben wie oft aus
dem den oben
ich war nie oben
ich war auf 8600 8700 und bin dann immer
wieder mit den teilnehmern umgekehrt
wenn ich es dieses mal schaffen
beschreibe ich einen artikel denn ich
begann als küchenjunge wurde siehe da
und habe etliche achttausender bestiegen
wie alt bist du jetzt 29 und 42
wir sind wirklich sehr sehr glücklich
dass wir euch beide bei uns zu haben
ich habe ein sehr gutes gefühl mit
durchzugehen
wir sind auch sehr glücklich so starke
mitglieder wir euch zu haben
im kommando zelt des expeditionsleiters
braten kari kobler und regie bolt mit
nobo das weitere vorgehen wenn der
everest freigegeben wird
wir planen 17 zelte fürs lager zu lager
vier brauchen wir vier zelte für die
members und wie viel für die sherpas
wir brauchen vier nur fielen dann
schlaff der zu dritt in einem zelt jaja
zu dritt in einem zelt dann solltet ihr
vorher duschen mit jedem tag warten wird
es auch für die sherpas schwieriger
einerseits sollten sie bereits die
weiteren hochlager bis auf 7900 meter
einrichten
andererseits verlieren sie einen
wichtigen teil ihres lohnes der von
ihrer leistung am berg abhängt falls die
chinesen den gipfel weiter blockieren
doch wie immer lassen sie sich nichts
anmerken
[Applaus]
ganz anders die expedition mitglieder
die für ihre besteigung 40000 franken
bezahlt haben
alles andere sind sind sind
spekulationen
[Musik]
zusätzlich verschlechtert sich nun das
wetter auch die chinesen können nicht
auf den gipfel
die nervosität im basislager steigt und
der druck auf die sherpas nimmt weiter
zu niemand weiß wann die chinesen
es gibt viel blabla es kann sein dass
wir am 6
starten können oder am vierten aber dann
ist sehr viel schärfer kraft nötig harte
arbeit um schnell nach oben zu kommen
harte arbeit von jedem sherpa das
passiert brauche ich eure power
manchmal braucht ihr mein geld manchmal
brauche ich eure paul etwas sind
wirklich viel stärker als die westler
wir sind seit der geburt an berge
gewöhnt dass es bei uns gehabt aber noch
etwas treibt die leute an geld und hier
gibt es gutes geld also müssen wir
arbeiten
inzwischen ist über eine woche vergangen
abwechslung steigt norbu mit den
expedition mitgliedern auf der
gegenseite zum tumore basecamp auf um
einen blick auf den etwas zu werfen
sie glauben die chinesen im aufstieg zu
sehen
so fiel auch die sherpas brauchen einen
ortswechsel zwei stunden fußmarsch vom
besten entfernt liegt gorbatschow auf
5180 metern die höchstgelegene lutz zu
der auch tracking gruppen kommen
die träger sind gezeichnet von der höhe
kaputt und müde
die sherpas tagen genießen jede freizeit
bei einem bier oder sie telefonieren mit
ihren familien die oft nur wenige
tagesetappen entfernt wohnen wie auch
die von london
für den jungen zierten norbu sherpa wird
das warten langsam ungemütlich einige
scheipers komm zu mir und sagen was
sollen wir die nächsten sechs tage
machen lasst uns schnell in die dörfer
nach unten gehen ich habe das bis jetzt
noch nicht erlaubt
ich sage wir müssten noch lager 3 und 4
aufbauen
sobald die olympische flamme oben ist
achter mai 2008 der tag der erlösung
die chinesen stehen auf den gipfel
über den combo eisfall bildet sich ein
regenbogen
[Musik]
im basecamp versammeln sich sherpas und
expedition mitglieder um die frohe
botschaft zu hören
die restriktionen sind aufgerufen ihr
seid frei hoch zu gehen
[Applaus]
endlich können die arbeiten im everest
weitergehen
15 starke sherpas aus den verschiedenen
expeditionsteams machen sich auf den weg
in den nächsten fünf tagen werden sie in
mehreren etappen vom lager 2 auf 6400
meter bis auf den gipfel auf 8850 meter
seil fixieren
alle sherpas der großen expeditionen
arbeiten hier zusammen
[Musik]
es ist eine überaus gefährliche arbeit
die sie hier im teilweise über 65 grad
steilen meisten gelände der lotse flanke
verrichten
die sherpas müssen technisch versiert
sein und jeden handgriff beherrschen
gern bis hin zur seite naja ok da haben
wir eine spalte gesehen wie wollen wir
vermeiden
[Musik]
in ein paar tagen werden sich insgesamt
über 500 zahlende gäste an diesen zeilen
hochziehen und sichern
[Musik]
inzwischen erreichen die schweizer
bergsteiger lager 2 sie werden sich hier
vorerst ausruhen bis alles bereit ist
euro erwartet willkommen im lager 82
kommt an mit weiterem material für die
hoch lagern
[Musik]
vom basislager aus koordiniert
expeditionsleiter kari kobler die
arbeiten und schaut dass der zeitplan
eingehalten wird
cam 2 von charlie antworten
der effekt wie geht es mit lager 3 sie
sind auf dem halben weg ins lager 3 und
fixieren die seile
heute abend werden sie lager drei
erreichen und morgen früh brechen auch
wir okay wer geht morgens lager drei ich
mal zu und insgesamt also vier sherpas
okay dann schicken wir auf die
teilnehmer sie sollen dort übernachten
nein übermorgen können sie ins lager 3
keine gute idee wenn ihr morgen früh die
zelte aufbaut sollte es gehen
bocelli
wir schauen morgen versucht es ohne
chappaz läuft nichts wir müssen alles
machen
wir sind wie leitern für die teilnehmer
wir bauen die sprossen und sie
erreichten den gipfel nur über diese
sprossen
inzwischen ist die gruppe welche die
seile in der josef lange fixiert hat
zurück eine weitere gruppe von sherpas
macht sich bereit für die nächste etappe
bis auf 7900 meter die sherpas aller
expeditionen organisieren sich
untereinander
es sind 16 leute lasst es uns in zwei
gruppen machen eine muss den gipfel
einrichten davon zwei von kari kobler
es sind sieben leute von kobler und
partner ist lang dort dabei erwartet
eine andere aufgabe er will mit seinen
sherpas das lager 3 auf 7300 meter
einrichten
morgen müssen etwas früher auch die
jungs der anderen teams gehen es sollte
keine missverständnisse über den ort
geben würden
wir können in drei stunden dort seien ja
wir sind die drei stunden dauert jetzt
eine stark und schnell nabu
transportiert morgen mit seinem team
material ins lager 3 auf 7.300 m
während dort die weitere säule bis auf
7900 meter verlegt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
schritt für schritt mit über 20 kilo
gepäck im rucksack mit zelten und
schlafsäcken der westlichen bergsteiger
ziehen sich norbu und seine sherpas die
wand der lotse flanke hoch
[Musik]
das sei einer der härtesten tage am
everest main tauber
ja
was ist passiert was du gefurzt aus
dänemark strömt gas einmal mehr
lassen sie sich nichts anmerken machen
witze während sie auf über 7000 metern
langsam
in die todeszone vorstoßen
[Musik]
einige schärferen nach nur einer
expedition mit dieser arbeit auf sie ist
physisch und mental sehr anstrengend
man braucht viel kraft wenn man jung ist
hat man diese kräfte diesen job kann man
nicht ewig machen
nach dem schweren dreistündigen aufstieg
beginnen die sherpas den platz für die
zelte vorzubereiten
in der lotse flanke zwischen
gletscherspalten entsteht lager 3 auf
7300 metern
lasst uns hier beginnen
wir können den schnee auf dieser seite
auf hatten
es ist ein gefährlicher exponierter
platz die sherpas müssen für jedes zelt
das eis aufhacken und den boden aus
ihnen das gelände fällt hier bis zu 45
grad steil an
inzwischen befinden sich dort die und
sein team bereits auf über 7.500 m
eine große held was gibt der held hat
schwer
wir müssen das seien hier mit einem
fairen anka fixieren
wir brauchen noch etliche auf dieser
seite
es ist eine gefährliche unberechenbare
arbeit in dünner luft vor allem wenn das
wetter wechselt kann der everest schnell
zu einer todesfalle werden
vor einigen jahren geriet dort wie hier
in der lawine und hat nur mit viel glück
überlebt
ich habe viele unfälle gesehen
freunde von mir sind am rs gestorben
einige sogar vor meinen augen leute
wurden von lawinen mitgerissen fielen in
gletscherspalten viele solche unfälle
wie fühlst du dich wenn du daran denkst
sehr traurig ich möchte weinen
ein freund von mir starb hier vor meinen
augen auch einige griffen gleichen zeit
schliefen hat es erwischt wenn ich daran
denke möchte ich niemals hierauf und nie
mehr diesen job verrichten
aber ich bin gezwungen zu arbeiten doch
es schmerzt wenn man daran denkt
weit weg in das heimatdorf pano geht das
leben seinen gewohnten weg dort ehefrau
passant i fakty kartoffel starten auf
dem feld vor dem aus es hat kein telefon
und weiß nicht wie es ihrem mann am
everest geht
ich pflege die kartoffeln bewies sie die
knoblauch starten jeder unkraut putzen
den garten laute solche arbeiten mit
deutscher weg ist in bergen
das ist meine arbeit im moment jeden
passanten der vorbeikommt fragt sie über
neuigkeiten vom everest bringen wenn
nicht bittet sie ihn sieht doch sofort
zu informieren wenn er etwas hört ich
warte auf indische zurückkommt und alles
gut geht
ich bin so glücklich nach seiner
rückkehr wenn es weiter schlecht wird
kennen wir viele dinge durch den kopf
um sich zu beruhigen praktiziert
passanten jahrhunderte alte rituale sie
präpariert reisschnaps der kaltgestellte
bis london bomberg zurückkommt das erste
glas trinkt ihr glaube gibt ihr kraft
wir gehen zum charakter oster in einer
jungen zu beten
einige tage bevor sie den gipfel in
angriff nehmen
das letzte mal dachte ich hier ins
kloster an diesem tag beten wir erneut
im kloster und führen das ganze ritual
durch
[Musik]
über 100 m s haben bis heute ihr leben
am airport train
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das team von um dort sie hat sich
inzwischen fast bis auf 7900 meter
vorgearbeitet und verlegt weitere sein
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
sollen wir umkehren
[Musik]
bruder bruder sie das seil ein wenig
auch narbe und die anderen sherpas haben
im lager drei ihr werk fast beendet sie
fixieren die zelte mit zeilen und firma
damit sie vom sturm nicht weggeweht
werden falls das wetter schlecht wird
alles ist nun bereit für die
expeditionsteilnehmer das camp von
kobler und partner steht alles ist gut
unsere freunde arbeiten am weg über eine
der schwierigsten aufgaben am everest
weil er heute erledigt
drei bis vier kobler und pannen
[Musik]
euro alt runter ins lager 2 im gegensatz
zu den westlern übernachten die sherpas
nie im lager 3 weil es seine zu hoch und
gefährlich ist im lager 2 ist die
küchenmannschaft dabei eis zu schmelzen
um wasser zu kochen die
expeditionsteilnehmer lassen es sich
hier gut gehen und sammeln ihre kräfte
vor sie am nächsten tag zum ersten mal
im lager drei übernachten werden
spät abends kommt ach longuet dem lager
2 an
was durch dem südviertel wir haben 400
meter seil am gelben band installieren
wir haben zwei rollen fixiert und zwei
rollen aufgenommen
also sind unsere freunde auf dem süd
sattel hermann kann sie dort oben sehen
[Musik]
im küchenzelt diskutieren die sherpas
weiter die seile zu fixieren war diesmal
schwierig letztes jahr lag dort viel
schnee
diesmal viel eis also ist es schwieriger
[Applaus]
am nächsten tag steigen auch die
expeditionsteilnehmer zum ersten mal ins
lager 3 auf während die sherpas direkt
vom lager zwei bis ins lager 4 auf 7900
meter hoch klettern um material zu
deponieren
am erweist
die sherpas der schweizer expedition
sind nicht alleine unterwegs
sherpas von allen 41 expeditionen haben
das gleiche ziel
auch sie tragen für ihre westlichen
bergsteiger die lebenswichtigen
sauerstoff flaschen ins lager 4
[Musik]
manche sherpas vergleichen bergsteigen
mit in den krieg ziehen in eine schlacht
aber für die neue generation ist es mehr
ein abenteuerspiel wir sind gebildet die
junge generation der sherpas ich
technisch besser geschult wir besuchen
kurse für bergsteigen für bergrettung
für lawinen die aussichten zu
verunfallen reduziert
[Musik]
doch nicht alle haben die wahl vor allem
für die älteren sherpas will um dort ist
dieser job die einzige
verdienstmöglichkeit die familie zu
ernähren
deshalb nehmen sie jedes jahr von neuem
die strapazen und risiken auf sich
[Musik]
dieser schärfe einer anderen expedition
trägt 12 sauerstoffflaschen also etwa 45
kilogramm auf 8.000 meter hoch woher er
die kraft nimmt kann niemand
nachvollziehen
inzwischen im lager drei bei den
schweizer bergsteigern
wir sind jetzt im lager 3 auf etwa 7200
meter ein wunderschönes lager hast du
dich auf den berg ich fühle mich
großartig weil die sherpas großartige
arbeit geleistet haben
die fixe eile und alles andere lehrer
bereits man muss nur dem seil folgen und
ins zelt sitzen
du bist also zufrieden mit dem cher
partie wir sind hervorragend und jenny
der ohne sauerstoff auf den gipfel
du hast schon sechs 8000 überstehen
was ist der unterschied zum everest
das ist der höchste bei anderen
expeditionen trifft man 20 leute hier
200 bis 300 ist das hart man muss sich
daran gewöhnen dann geht s es macht ihr
nichts aus
es ist normal
[Gelächter]
während die expeditionsteilnehmer sich
nun entspannen stauen sich die sherpas
im aufstieg einmal mehr
[Musik]
heute hat es zu viele leute man kann die
bergsteiger fast nicht über ruhigen
einige laufen schnell andere langsam
es stockt es wäre einfacher wenn alle
gleich schnell marschieren würden aber
so ist das laufen völlig des organisiert
in arizona
[Musik]
mama
nach sieben stunden erreichen die ersten
sherpas von kari kobler das lager 4 auf
7900 meter sie besetzen eine lagerplatz
deponieren ihre lasten rund 50
sauerstoffflaschen die über leben und
tod entscheiden
vorsichtshalber versehen sie die
flaschen mit einem schloss man kann nie
wissen
es wird kalt wegen des windes
einige unserer freunde sind noch nicht
da wir schließen sie sauerstoff flaschen
ab jeder von uns hat einen schlüssel
[Applaus]
auch london
sie hat es geschafft im pulk musste er
immer wieder warten und hat viel energie
verbraucht ich bin heute zum ersten mal
auf dem sattel
einige sind schon wieder zurückgegangen
ich definiere hier die
sauerstoffflaschen und andere sachen
drei freunde
es sind noch hinter mir es ist etwas
windig nebel kommt auf aber es ist immer
noch okay nicht gefährlich alles ist
noch gut so schnell als möglich machen
sie sich wieder auf den abstieg ihre
arbeit ist nun getan
alles ist eingerichtet und bereit für
den gipfelsturm
im gegensatz zu den sherpas verbringen
die schweizer bergsteiger noch eine
nacht zur akklimatisation im lager 3 auf
7300 meter bevor sie auch ins basislager
absteigen richtfunk mit chef kari kobler
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die natur am everest ist fantastisch
aber auch gefährlich
norbu und die anderen sherpas sind
glücklich nach all den harten tagen
wieder heil im basislager einzutreffen
wäre ich in kathmandu würde mir jetzt
meine freundin helfen mein gepäck im
zelt zu versteuern
aber hier bin ich alleine ich muss alles
selber erledigen
mein gepäck schleppen das ist wie eine
ein mann armee
die kleider sind zum waschen denken sie
keine frage man fühlt sich ganz
besonders
selbst fische würden sterben jährlich
sie ins hause halten würde
giftiger abfall alle arbeit der sherpas
jetzt müssen wir nur noch die teilnehmer
auf dem gipfel bringen
wir warten auf diesen tag wie sieht das
wetter aus bis jetzt ist das wetter
schön aber ich weiß nicht wie es sich
weiter entwickeln wird
inzwischen sind auch die schweizer
bergsteiger wieder im basislager bevor
sie zum gipfel aufsteigen besuchen sie
die bäckerei im basecamp sie wird von
geschäftstüchtigen sherpas während der
expedition zeit betrieben sagt er jeden
morgen frisch ja der absolute renner ist
der lauwarme schokoladenkuchen so
versüßen sie sich das warten auf ein
schönes wetter fenster von drei bis vier
tagen für den gipfelsturm
sie wissen dass der everest bei
schlechtem wetter leicht zur todesfalle
werden kann
kari hat eine wetterstation aufgebaut
und es täglichem kontakt mit dem wetter
büro meteotest in bern welches ihnen die
aktuellen daten per satellit durch gibt
die meisten everest besteigung finden
mitte bis ende mai stand kurz vor dem
beginn des monsuns dann sind die winde
besonders günstig
was man ungefähr für eine temperatur
hand auf 350 bar als machten sich die
100 meter um die 20 stunden 400 meter
paul hanny sich selber so - 18 uhr das
egal
als mainz mehr als minus 30 grad ish
damit das leben nicht wagen aber soweit
durch heirat perfekt mal
ich lese dem aargau ja die auch für den
gipfelsturm bekommt jetzt jeder
bergsteiger seinen persönlichen sherpa
zugeteilt der ihn während des aufstiegs
zum glück begleitet er versucht doch wie
gut die mission sache stark sache wäre
eigentlich schon so gut eigentlich dass
der gutti musik genie und richard könnte
vermutlich sowieso das lösen mit den
antworten und drang zu recht gut
englisch technisch super stars und die
menge maschinen nabu betont noch einmal
dass die teilnehmer die hilfe der
sherpas auch beim abstieg in anspruch
nehmen können
dieses mal sind alle bergsteiger stark
aber oft ist dies nicht der fall
mit einem schwachen teilnehmer musste
bei schlechtem wetter immer den
karabiner ein hang du musst im wasser
geben immer musst du die handschuhe
ausziehen das risiko zu verunglücken ist
größer wenn der teilnehmer schwach ist
manchmal macht es den schalkern richtig
aggressiv wenn er mit einem schwachen
unterwegs ist
wir dürfen es nicht zeigen wir sind
dafür bezahlt im basecamp können wir mit
unseren freunden darüber reden aber
nicht mit den anderen teilnehmern dann
instruiert kari kobler seinen teilnehmer
über den umgang mit sauerstoff die luft
auf 8.000 meter ist so dünn dass der
mensch durch sauerstoffmangel willen
krank werden und daran sterben kann als
einziger weg wichtig ist wenn irgendwo
ein lied sangen wir trotzdem ohne
sauerstoff aufsteigen aus
bergsteigerische ehrgeiz will er alle
achttausender ohne sauerstoff bezwingen
er werde der bahnhof stelle wo ganz klar
sein wo sich jeder muss der halter und
solange sich jeder die regler halt
machen mit alles damit nun passiert wenn
sich einfach über die regler haltet den
muss ich einfach sagen denn ist ein
ominöses business wenn irgendwas
passiert oder will es zeichnet sie das
cerp offenen teilnehmerkreis kreiere wo
einfach irgendwie bis colossos zeit auch
nabu platz einen sherpas
ein letztes mal ein worauf sie achten
müssen ein sherpa muss am gipfeltag
immer seinen teilnehmer begleiten
er darf seinen teilnehmer unter gar
keinen umständen verlassen
er muss sie noch wieder runter bringen
ins lager 3 er ist manchmal ist der
teilnehmer vor dem schöpfer manchmal
dahinter und umgekehrt
aber ihr dürft nie davon ausgehen dass
der teilnehmer automatisch nachkommt wir
müssen zusammen mit ihm gehen wenn der
teilnehmer nicht mehr mag müsst ihr mit
ihm umkehren und das sehen sie in der
nächsten folge
aufbruch zum gipfel des everest in der
nacht mit über 100 anderen bergsteigern
[Musik]
sherpas und bergsteiger sind gefordert
jubel auf dem gipfel doch ein drama
überschattet die expedition ein
teilnehmer wird höhenkrank und bringt
auch seinen körper in lebensgefahr
ich dachte wir würden beide sterben
dies und mehr in der nächsten folge von
sherpas die wahren helden am everest